Hey traders, it's Mike here. And uh
today is the last trading day of May uh
2026. It's the uh 29th of May and uh
what a way to end out the month. You
know, it's interesting with the order
flow entry model.
Um you know, during the normal US
sessions there over the last couple days
in the E-minis hasn't been many trades.
Uh but today we did manage to
isolate a few. There was one uh just uh
right before the close here about uh
2:00 Chicago time 2:02. There's an
exhaustion print that's coming into this
nice swing low here and it makes a nice
move up from around uh you know, 87 all
the way up into It didn't quite get up
to 97, but had a nice move up to around
the 94 95 area where it was just sort of
consolidating up here. Um you know, what
was nice about this move is it had the
uh
nice uh prominent point of control here.
It's point of control towards the
bottom. You had a couple of buying
imbalances as well. Okay. Now, you know,
the delta again, you know, this market
was kind of quiet most of this day. You
know, this yellow line is the uh
is the opening price. You know, the
futures open uh they close at 4:00 p.m.
then they reopen at 5:00 p.m. And if
we're on Friday afternoon just hanging
around um the opening price, which is
essentially pretty close to the closing
price, you know, it's uh it's a quiet
day.
Uh I thought today would be a little bit
more exciting, especially, you know,
when looking at the uh
looking at the chart the way that the
overnight session was. This is the
overnight session right here. You see
we're in a very tight range last night
here uh for most of the morning until
the cash open, then we shot up once the
cash open, came back down and we just
literally hung around unchanged most of
the day essentially. Um you know, this
was the overnight high. You know, we
spent a lot of time above it, but we
couldn't really get past the the high
that we made after the cash open. And we
just again, you know, we we're closing
uh you know, not that far off of uh
yesterday's close.
So, that's why I was expecting a little
bit more activity, you know, normally we
get a bigger range like uh yesterday,
you know, our range from tonight's uh or
last night's uh session, or the
overnight session is about half of what
we saw yesterday. You saw yesterday we
got a big rally, whereas today it was
kind of kind of muted. Um that's why
again, you know, I said I was expecting
once we started breaking out to those
highs during the US hours, I was I was
kind of looking for a little bit more uh
activity.
Now we did have another buy here. This
one
you know, it came off this big green bar
actually.
And you know, the auction printed 10.
This was a kind of a smaller move, and
it just didn't really go anywhere. Even
though it did go up, you know, it spent
most of the time, you know, did make
this half-hearted move from around 03 up
to 08. So about a five-point move only,
and then you sort of started drifting
back down on all this uh negative delta
right around to break even. You know, if
you got a point or two out of this move,
that was uh probably good. I mean, the
most you could have got out of it is
maybe five points.
Um you know, the only drawback on this
one, it's kind of a
a a negative I guess is, you know, this
bar was was quite big. You know, you're
talking from about uh 75.95 and a
quarter is the low all the way up to 02.
So about a seven-point bar, which is
kind of big relative to the surrounding
bars. You know, that's going to make
your your risk um you know, that much.
But again, you know, this trade didn't
didn't have any drawdown. Um and again,
you know, by the time you're over here
11:49, you mean you'd be getting getting
long here at 11:34. So about 15 minutes
have passed, and it's starting to come
back down with all this negative delta.
It's not a good sign if you're looking
for this market to shoot back up. Yeah,
it's not going to shoot back up on all
this negative delta. So, you know, it it
was this
not the best move, but you know, you
could have
salvaged something out of there.
But uh you know, the other good moves
though
well, I don't say good moves, the other
you know, interesting moves in this
market came uh just ahead of the cash
open. Now, there was one here just
scrolling back. This one
you know, I I don't recommend sort of
that uh
cash market window pre-open. This one
came in at uh around 8:05 this morning.
You know, cash opens here at 8:30. So,
you know, it's going to market just
going to quiet down. So, even though
this did trade lower,
it's not a it's not encouraging, you
know, in the sense that you you're
generally not going to get a big move,
especially this market when you look at
what happened overnight with the tight
range. You're not expecting a big move
to come in right ahead of the cash open.
You know, it's like everyone's just
waiting for the cash to open.
So, you don't you know, I'm not
surprised to see this kind of uh small
move there. But again, I wouldn't even
bother with taking a trade at 8:30 at
8:00 right ahead of the cash open at
8:30. Um you had this other one here,
this this long coming in around just
before 7:00. And
you know, again, on a very big green
candle. I don't really like to take
trades off of these big green candles,
but it you know, the green candle's
coming off a big red candle. So, it sort
of flipped itself. You know, and then
you know, you're looking you're getting
long around the 91. It starts going up
and just sort of hangs around there for
the next you know,
half hour.
But again, you know, you're not going to
stick around in a trade
for 30 minutes.
It
you you got plenty of time to get maybe
a point out of this trade.
Maybe again, I don't think you would
have got out up here. Somewhere in here,
hopefully you could have got out of or
scratch the trade. But again, you know,
it's 7:00 in the morning.
You know, how much how much capacity is
there for a a nice move? Um bonds, ultra
bonds rather, we we start the uh this
first notice day, so we start the roll.
There was no uh trades in the bonds
during the US hours. There was was short
up here last night.
Uh this came in, you know, around 8:00
p.m. Chicago time and it was the high of
the day. And again, I'm not saying
you're going to get short at 8:00 p.m.
and hold it all the way until 9:00 a.m.
Um honestly, trading bonds
in the uh evening session
Chicago hours is going to be like
watching paint dry. So, you know, even
though you look back, you know, you wake
up in the morning and say, "Oh, you
know, I could have taken that trade." I
mean, be realistic. You I mean, you're
not going to be sitting I mean,
especially at the basketball game last
night.
Um
Eurocurrency, um
there was a couple trades that didn't
work out here
um during the US hours right here.
There's a short.
There's a short here, a short here. You
know, it started to go, it started to
go, but they failed. You know, these
would just stop you out in two bars
later. Um
Get back over here, what was
interesting. See, you had one around
8:30 this morning, 8:20. It started to
work, okay? It but this gives you an
idea how slow the market is, right? So,
you're getting an exhaustion print
where? You're getting an exhaustion
print at the opening price, which is
essentially the closing price from
yesterday, right here. This yellow line
is that level.
And you know, this coming in around 8:20
and then we just sort of drift lower
here until, you know, 9:40.
I mean, it's in your favor most of the
most of the trade. You know, it does get
a little bit of a pullback up here, but
everything else is sort of in your
favor. So, again, you know, you're
getting short at 8:20. It's 9:00. If
you're not out already, you should just
you could cut it. You know, it's it was
a quiet day.
Um
even just taking it a little further
back
uh
you know, yesterday from yesterday's
high of the day yesterday, you did have
this bearish signal and it sold off all
the way into the next morning.
Um
you know,
right? This is at uh what? 11:24
in the afternoon all the way until uh
midnight where it uh
got all the way down here.
Uh right down here.
So,
again, you know, euro currency it was a
little bit more tougher today than uh
than it has been. Now, you know, what
was interesting though is, you know, I
always suggest traders also keep an eye
on other markets is British pound today,
you know, while British pound today was
nice, you know, you had this nice
exhaustion print on the low of the day
and it rallied up. You know, this was
nice. It was coming in hot. Look at this
delta minus 748,
minus 298, minus 190, minus 163, minus
144. As we keep making these new lows,
another new low 78 and then 58s
positive. These are positives. So, even
though we got strong selling coming down
in here with the negative deltas,
they're getting weaker on all on the way
down. We finally get your exhaustion
print here and the market reverses,
trades all the way up to the highs,
makes new highs where you get another
exhaustion print up here, bearish one
this time. And look at this. Now the
selling really shows its hand up here.
Minus 576, minus 121, minus 321, minus
547, minus 293, minus 166, minus 746.
This happened around 10 and then, you
know, we just
go lower from there. This is right
around that uh
77 134 77. Gets all the way down into
the 50s here, 57. So, that's like 20
ticks.
But this was the beautiful move right
here.
Now,
um
you know, so today, you know, while euro
currency sort of struggled, British
pound performed well. Now, let's take a
look at uh couple of these other
markets, the the mini Dow and crude oil.
Let's start with the mini Dow.
Yeah, this one is 7 minutes for the
futures close.
Um, you know, you got this line from
yesterday still there. Here was a short.
This one, but well, it wasn't a short.
It was a signal. You had your exhaustion
print, but the next two bars don't go
below the low of the signal bar, so no
trade there.
Um,
let's go back a little bit more.
You got I see this exhaustion print. You
see how this market came right down to
that exhaustion print from earlier.
Just touched it. You know, here it is
right here. This was a nice one. Um,
here's your
exhaustion print right here.
Get this out of the way.
Um,
you know, you you come in here the
negative delta is kind of small. I mean,
it's it's Dow. You're not going to get
like minus 300 minus 400 on the regular.
It's going to be generally pretty small,
but you know, you're looking at around
getting long somewhere in here around uh
whatever that is, 985. Shoots all the
way up to, you know, close to
8551 085, but you know,
this is a beautiful move up before it
starts reversing and comes back down.
Clearly comes back down to the level
here. But you know, this is a easy 50
points. I mean, you're talking 980 up to
060 070 080 up here, but you know,
that's almost 100 points, but again, you
know, the the meat of the trade is good
50 ticks right there.
Um, what else do we got here in the year
in the
This one
started to go, but it just uh just
couldn't quite get there, all right?
Just a little bit of selling left over.
You know, minus 13 minus 40, then it
turns positive 44. You got your
exhaustion print here. You got a nice
move down developing. Pops up here.
Spends the next couple minutes hanging
around your entry before it comes down,
stops you out before it makes that move
up. And again, you know, you're you're
looking at, you know, a move from 30 all
the way up to 80. That's your 50-point
move, but there was just a little bit of
selling in there to to knock you out of
that trade.
So sort of go back here. This one is
again, this one's a nice one.
Getting long in here.
Is your exhaustion print again, you
know, consistent selling on the way
down. All these negative deltas coming
in here.
Turns positive here finally. Your
exhaustion print of one contract gets
you in on the next bar.
Again, this one's a nice cuz it's got a
kind of a tight
you know, it's not a huge bar up. So you
know, stop is pretty decent. Does pull
you back. Does test your stop level cuz
your stop level is just going to be
right here.
Okay.
And then it move makes this move. So
you're talking a move from around you
know, 45
all the way up into you know, above
5100. That's 5100 is 60 points, 60 ticks
rather.
Or
uh sorry, 105 here. 60 ticks, but you
know, good 50.
Does get all the way up to one doesn't
hit 140. 140 was the high.
But um you know, this was a nice solid
one there.
Again, with very little basically didn't
even pull back on you.
Um you was a short here. This was around
9 just before 10:00 this morning at the
high of the day. Again, started to go
down and then it just hangs around,
right? You getting short here just
before 10:00. It's 10:15 more or less
here before it comes out and stops you
out.
Again, you know, you're you're getting
short. You're looking for the move.
It's just never developed. It's going
this way. It's going horizontal instead
of vertical down.
Right? So you know, at some point you
got to realize, hey, you know what? This
trade is not paying me off.
Maybe I should get out. You know, you
could have got out a small winner, small
loser would have been fine as well.
Rather than a full stop out, but even
this full stop out it's not a deep one.
Um that that's going to you know, knock
you out of the market for the day.
Uh
it was a short as well.
Yeah, started you know, started going
down in in your favor.
It's a nice little short here getting
short around 940. Gets all the way down
below 900. So, that's you know,
40 points, 40 ticks rather.
Um it just sort of hangs around here.
You know, this is first hour of cash.
So, you know, it's still moving around
pretty nicely. Um
This was interesting because right after
the cash you had a buy and a sell.
This one here was a buy.
Didn't even pull This is the best type
of trade where it doesn't even pull
back. This is just
you know, we opened up on this bar here,
this green candle. Went down a little
bit and then just shot straight up. You
know, we're talking a move from about 7
795.
Okay?
Gets all the way up
over 100 points.
To
right up here.
795 up to 895. You do get your bearish
signal here. This one stopped you out.
Get another one stopped you out. But you
know, you you the best trades are the
ones that work immediately. So,
you know, this was a nice trade here
early. So, you know, again, I'm always
hesitant on these big bars to get long
or get short because your risk is just
too big.
All right? I I I just I I prefer, you
know, to take trades
on shorter bars like this one here or
even um you know, we had that other
trade here. It's a nice little short
bar, you know, from 41 getting long
around 43.
To 27.
So, you know, what? Less than 20 ticks
of risk. Now, let's take a look at
crude. Crude is interesting as well. Um
You know, crude I love seeing crude back
in the '80s. You know, hopefully it'll
it'll keep uh dropping
back down to '60s so it's not going to
cost me $100 to fill up my car.
Um this one
and this one this one no trade cuz we
don't go lower here. This one started to
but okay, went up here tagged your got
within one tick of your stop came back
down before went up here and stopped you
out. unlucky
Um but
earlier prior to that you did have this
nice exhaustion print here getting short
right here. Nice move down and this is a
beautiful move from around, you know,
or sorry, 8715 down into the the '60s
down in here even down here 75.
Uh
Let's see what else. This was
This was a
There's a couple here. So, this was a
short, right? You get short here and
then again it just goes sideways. You
got to be realizing
it's you don't wait for it to go
sideways for 10 minutes and then make
the move. If it's not making the move in
10 minutes
get out.
Take your loss. Take your small profit.
Take your scratch.
Best moves happen right away. This one
also you get long and then there's one
two three four minutes. It's just small
in the money before it comes down here
and stops you out. If market's going to
move off of exhaustion, if it's going to
be a reversal off of exhaustion, it
should happen sooner rather than later.
Right? Again, it's not like you're going
to wait for 10 minutes, 15 minutes.
There's another one. This one This one
also stopped you out. Um
You're looking you're trading a
reversal. The reversal's got to happen.
This was a nice one again but you know,
this one's a bit sketch because it's
such a big bar here.
I'm scared of bars like this. This is
almost a 100 tick bar.
But, you know, again, if you got balls
to trade 100 ticks bar, get short off of
it.
Yeah, you're getting short in here, 87,
you know, 90 somewhere in uh
80 rather.
Uh maybe 75.
You do take some heat. Does get up to uh
15 more or less. But, this one
you know, big risk, bigger reward. You
know, it trades all the way down to 86
35. So close to, you know, well over a
$1 move. More like a dollar
over Well, I mean, I don't want to say,
you know, I'm not going to say, "Oh, you
would have covered it down here." No,
you know, the the the gist of the move
is somewhere down in here where it
starts to go sideways even here.
Um cuz these are all just vertical bars
going down. It's not till the market
starts going horizontal that you should
think of getting out. So, again, you're
getting short uh
somewhere up in here.
You know, to cover it somewhere down in
here is fine.
Or even in here.
80 so, you know, from here to here is
100 ticks.
Again, I just don't like that big
big bar.
Um
these two aren't trades. I mean, you got
this exhaustion signal here and here,
but we don't go lower
than the signal bar. Well, this one did
went by one tick. This one no.
Again, you know, you get stopped out
there, but then you catch this monster
move
uh right after that.
Whoops.
And uh
Again, this one is a signal, but no
trade cuz we don't go higher. We're not
even going to mark that out.
Uh you know, here's a move.
Again, you know, take a look at these
moves. So, here's your exhaustion. It's
a big bar as well, but get short. Best
moves happen right away. They don't just
sort of go sideways and then move. They
should come down.
Stop here. It should just start moving.
Period.
Okay. This
looks big, but it's only about a uh
40 cent move.
But hey, 40 cents is 40 cents. This one
was This one would stop you out. Get
short here. Okay, but it's a tight stop.
It's about 10 ticks.
And
okay, it's about 6:00 in the morning
here. This was a nice one. I'll send it
up on this positive note. Your
exhaustion print here.
Next bar goes inside a little bit, and
then second bar, boom. Short 8770.
Gets down to 71, 8671. So, almost 100
points.
But again, you know, this one started
out going sideways. Now, remember it it
was on the second bar you got short,
then 1 2 3 before it started to move.
And then it dropped, right? You're not
looking for it to go like this. Get a
bar here, a bar here, a bar here, a bar
here, a bar here, and then here, and
then wait for it to start dropping. It's
It's going to take off sooner.
Right? Getting short. Well, this is your
exhaustion print, but this is your bar
you're getting short on.
And then it just sort of hangs around
for 1 2 3 bars.
On the third bar is when it really
starts dropping. And then
it just dropped precipitously pretty
quick.
So, anyway, that's the sort of the recap
there. It's the end of the month today.
I
wanted to get this video out for you
guys really quick. Um so, you guys could
enjoy the uh
weekend. And yeah, man. So,
thanks for watching this video. I hope
you guys are starting to use the
exhaustion entry model.
Um you know, I'm showing you on on
different markets. I do believe it's
it's a market or sorry, it's a entry
It's a trading system that you can use
on different markets, right? I I I I
have the same settings that I'm using on
YM, on CL, on
ultra bonds, on euro currency, on
e-minis. Right, these are all same
1-minute charts. Well, currencies are
and ultra bonds are range-based charts.
But again, you know, you can see how it
is transferable into different markets.
So, have a great weekend everyone and
I'll catch you guys next week.